l'exécution fédéral par rapport à
l'expulsion de l'état veut dire que le
prisonnier a été condamné par une
autorité fédérale
[Musique]
non
les etats unis sont donc l'état fédéral
ce qui veut dire qu'il ya deux types
d'autorité chaque état à la disposition
au tout le panel judiciaire et
répressive qui souhaitent mettre en
place c'est seulement il peut se poser
un problème si par exemple le crime
concert de deux états si le meurtrier et
de californie et que la victime et du
nevada on va se demander où juger ce cas
là est ce que ça va être californie
nevada les vous doutez bien action vous
êtes victimes ou coupables forcément
vous n'allez pas vouloir être même
endroit suivre la pète qui va être
appliqué et en particulier la peine de
mort certains et à l'appli d'autres ne
l'appliquent pas pour éviter cela dans
ce type de cas c'est l'état fédéral qui
juge quand il ya plusieurs états
concernés
[Musique]
une image que tout le monde connaît ces
séries vous regardez où des policiers
sont en train de mener l enquête et tout
d'un coup on voit arriver dans le salle
ces policiers en costume noir avec leurs
cravates et pour faire le tableau
complet leurs lunettes de soleil qu'ils
disent bonjour je suis le fbi a et je
reprends le dossier fb il veut dire
fédéral veut tenir ces dossiers est trop
grand pour vous
[Musique]
injection létale qui sont très disputées
aux etats unis puisque actuellement la
question est de savoir si c'est pas du
bon à savoir si les personnes ne souffre
pas une fois qu'elles sont dans un état
de coma puis ce qui en fait il ya deux
injections une première qui met la
personne en état de léthargie où on
présume qu'ils ne souffrent pas et
ensuite celle qui donne la mort et c'est
là où il ya eu d'ambiguïté et où les
défenseurs droits de l'homme disent que
c'est inhumain
or la constitution interdit les
exécutions si elles sont inhumaines donc
l'état fédéral a suspendu c'est ces
exécutions ne sachant pas quelle réponse
apporter c'est vrai que depuis 2003 les
prisonniers mouret leur bâton de
vieillesse la paix peut être me peut
être exécutée maintenant à n'importe
quel moment une fois que les délais de
grâce et et de et de recours ont été
dépassés
alors ça a été remis au goût du jour
j'ai envie de dire en tout cas poussés
par donald trump qui avait fait de cette
question une question fondamentale dans
sa compagne et c'est vrai qu'après cet
attentat de 2017 à new york
le débat était devenu très aiguë la
question est donc remonté à la cour
suprême qui a emprunté peu de temps la
cour suprême et c'est vrai cette
question a été tranchée dans quelques
jours c'était fin juin la cour suprême a
estimé qu'il y avait aucune raison que
l'état fédéral n'applique pas la peine
de mort pour ceux qui le méritaient
c'est une nouvelle très important parce
que ça va à contre courant de ce qui se
passe en réalité dans l'opinion
si en 1990 80 à 85 % des américains
étaient favorables à la peine de mort
actuellement ils sont à parité
quarante cinq 45 et le reste ne se
prononcent pas il y a une tendance à
aller justement vers l'élimination de la
peine de mort puisqu'aujourd'hui il y a
techniquement une trentaine d'états
qu'ils appliquent encore mais en réalité
il n'ya plus que 21
c'est le contraire que fait la cour
suprême en réactivant elle était
toujours là à la peine de mort bien en
tout cas en réactivant un endroit où le
droit de l'art est appliquée sas a
surpris beaucoup de bombes
[Musique]
les bras
voilà